oh I'm nervous for this one yeah and
there's this one okay
well I'll tell you why I'm nervous in a
few minutes holy nation we are doing a
tour of 23 cities across the United
States and I'm looking forward to
meeting you Lena has quit her job oh and
it's me Nina
and Danny the three of us gonna go over
90 days three months traveling to 23
different cities meeting you and also
exploring it's a very scary thing for me
that will explain in the second but the
origin of this is because I told Nina
that I take it every city in North
America with a million plus people and
there's like 50 or something in the u.s.
like that and so we're gonna hit 23 of
them on this trip and the initial idea
was to do a coffee shop meet up this is
where it gets serious because I love
meeting you guys when I'm traveling
meeting you guys as to my favorite and
so the initial idea was we're gonna do a
coffee shop meet up in every city and
then I went to New York we just got back
last weekend and met with my agent Steve
and he told me that I was playing small
and I'm not that I'm that I'm afraid to
take risks yeah and to do something
bigger and he was right
and we also did a coffee shop meet up in
New York and we had too many people
there and it was not a fantastic
experience because not everybody could
hear me and we just had too many people
there which is a good problem I have but
as my audience I guess gets bigger and
as we try to do more of this stuff it's
gonna be harder to keep it up a coffee
shop so my agent said you have to do
something that scares you and you should
charge for the event and that's curious
it's curious because I'm worried that
that one's gonna show up t when you come
and give you a lot of team oh come here
give me love you
so now I was needing love okay good boy
okay
we love you MA it scares me because I'm
worried that was gonna show up and I
remember my very first speaking gig at
the YMCA in Toronto there was three
people that showed up and how bad that
felt and now we've got it
this is like a nightmare for me that
I've got to do 20 22 22 speaking gigs
basically really a nightmare for every
four days and the the ability to fail
again and again and again so that's
awesome that's happening and I feel bad
too because you know I don't know I just
feel bad I feel bad I feel bad I feel
bad because I still resonate with being
like the startup entrepreneur who can't
afford anything so we are doing a we're
doing the 22 city 23 city tour we're
gonna be doing a paid event we're
launching the website that has all the
details on it the events gonna be three
hours in an evening 6:30 to 9:30 in each
city and it's gonna lead with me talking
about what's on my mind and then it's
Q&A like I want I want to help you guys
out I want to know what's on your mind
I want to I want it to be valuable I
want it so that when you come it's an
important use of everybody's time
because I'm so afraid of letting people
down and hate the idea that I
potentially let somebody down it's great
for you because then I over deliver and
make sure I bring the best of myself and
hopefully if you're in any of the cities
that we're going to I'd love for you to
come with your most important question I
think you need help with the most and
leave with an answer with an action plan
we're going to be doing a whole bunch of
prizes that will be coming out we'll be
announcing that in the near future but
for now if we want to check out the
different cities were hitting up we will
link up the website below we can go
check it out how you feel about all this
you quit your job you did the scary
thing butter it up
yeah es a Neena quit her job she's a
tour manager if you email any ideas or
requests to tour at Evan Carmichael calm
and a go to Mia she'll be responding yes
oh she's never said it's not gonna go
well and I'm worried I feel bad for you
and I'm worried about you me yeah
because you yeah yeah we'll get through
it together we'll get through it
together
Nina's plans are unknown apps if she
comes back does she go back does she
just stay with me and help plan the next
tour or do some more work or go back and
get another job or do something else
we're bringing Danny with us who's gonna
be filming everything in documenting the
journey just quick on that note Danny's
hero is Arnold Schwarzenegger we're
trying to meet him in California if
anybody has a connection to that please
let us know you will make Danny's not
just here but life and then for me
[Applause]
please come to behave your heads you're
so sweet mmm we love this girl
please come to the event it would mean a
lot to me I'm scared and the tour is
called become and the idea is I want you
to become more become confident become
greater become successful and I want any
energy that you spend with me to be
meaningful and it's also my become
journey because this is something that
I'm terrified to do and it's not just
one event but 22 separate ones and so
yeah I get that I get that get up and
possibly fail and then go do that again
every four days so it's a tough decision
it's a tough video to make and we're
gonna have a fun ride and see how it
goes see if we can handle 90 days to
support of the year 90 days on the earth
I would love your feedback I would love
your questions again you can check out
the route that we're going on we'll
leave the link in the description and if
you have any thoughts questions advice
what I'm planning to do is make this of
a series until we launch where I update
you on how the tour is coming along new
new development that we've made but if
you have questions as well or
suggestions will read out some of the
comments on next week's video join us on
our futon journey and hopefully you
become and I become and we become
together have some fun if you want the
link to go check out the tour check it
out it's right there next to us you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and we'll
see you there